Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Fußball der Männer und sprechen heute über die Premier League, die Serie A, die Liga äh und La Liga, das tun wir mit Nils Kahn, Uli Hebel, Mario Rieker und Alexi Menüch jetzt hier im RASFUNK. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer und hallo und herzlich willkommen an eine fast ebenso große Runde hier. Guten Morgen, ihr vier. Ihr sagt es einfach einmal gesammelt, guten Morgen. Da sparen wir gleich mal Zeit an. Guten Morgen. Ganz fantastisch. Ich liebe diese morgendlichen Zusammenknöpfe. Kurz Hand hoch, wer hat gestern Abend noch arbeiten müssen? Bei Mario weiß ich es, bei Neil weiß ich alle. Uli, du nicht?
Nee, ich nicht. Ich habe zwar trotzdem ein bisschen was gemacht, aber…
Ja, gut, klar. Das ist ja eh logisch. Ja, verrückt. Stark, stark. Und dennoch treffen wir uns alle hier an einem Feiertag. Ganz herzlichen Dank an euch alle. Und schön auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass ihr hier seid und dass es so gutes Feedback zur letzten Ausgabe gab. Wir wollen direkt reinstarten in die Neue. Und nachdem wir Alexi schon so lange nicht mehr gehört haben, würde ich sagen, Alexi, fang du doch gerne mit deinem Thema an. Du wirst uns heute was über die AS Monaco erzählen. Was gibt es denn da zu berichten?
Ja, ich hätte es lieber mit einem Sieg in Zagreb gemacht, aber ich habe nur in 2-2 gestern nach 0-2 Rückstand. Trotzdem sieht es gut aus für die AS Monaco.
Mit gelb roter Karte für Nenad Bielica als neuen zagreb-trainer. Kann man sich das überhaupt vorstellen? Verrückt.
Aber gegen ihn, so mal zwei Punkte zu verlieren, tut schon weh. Man hat schon das Gefühl nach sechs Spieltagen der Liga einfach, dass Monaco womöglich die einzige Mannschaft ist, die Paris saint-germain entthronen kann. Natürlich hat PSG halt, und dem Papi Neymar und Messi, ein anderes Gesicht. Und wir haben einen trainer, der vielleicht der arroganteste trainer aller Zeiten ist, und der mittlerweile richtig Probleme bekommt bei PSG sportlich, auch mit den Medien, weil er sie wirklich respektlos behandelt. Und das könnte für ihn zum eigenen Tor führen, Klamazou, sodass davon Monaco profitieren könnte. Die Frage ist halt, ob Monaco, Champions League und Ligue 1 mixen kann, ob man mit beiden Wettbewerben gut umgehen kann. Bisher sieht es nicht schlecht aus. Monaco hat vier Punkte in der Champions League. Um das Restprogramm her müsste es reichen, zu den Playoffs im Februar. Und in der Ligue 1, wie gesagt, hat man schon das Gefühl, wenn man sich auch die Breite des Kaders anschaut, mit einem relativ starken Bundesliga-Aktent, mit Zakaria, mit Mbolo, natürlich auch Tilo Kehrer, der wieder erstarkte Vizekapitän, also die Hüte als trainer, dass diese Mannschaft qualitativ und quantitativ besser besetzt ist als Olympique Lyon oder Olympique de Marseille. Insofern, da ich es nicht nur ärgern und sogar Meister werden könnte am Ende des saisons.
Ist ja auch eins von drei ungeschlagenen Teams noch in der Ligue 1, PSG ist dabei, L'Anse ist dabei noch zu nennen, aber die haben vier Mal schon unentschieden gespielt, deswegen haben die wesentlich weniger Punkte. Jetzt ist es ja nicht die erste saison von Adi Hütter. Gibt es denn eine Entwicklung bei ihm zu sehen oder hat er Monaco immer mehr zu seinem Team gemacht?
Ja, er hatte schon Schwierigkeiten vor genau einem Jahr, als es nicht richtig lief. Man muss nicht vergessen, Max, dass offiziell heißt es, dass die Eismann auch kurz zum Verkauf steht. Man weiß aber nicht, wie die Verhandlungen stehen, ob es überhaupt noch Verhandlungen gibt zwischen dem russischen Milliardär Rivolovlev und wohl ein saudiarabisches Unternehmen. Man hört gar nichts mehr, weil in Monaco ist alles diskret. Da kommt einfach nichts raus. Man ist nicht an der Säbener Straße, man ist am Fürstentum und da kommt einfach nichts raus. Egal, ob Transfergerüchte oder jetzt, wenn es um die Zukunft des Vereins geht. Und wenn morgen ein saudiarabisches Konzern kommt und Monaco kauft, dann kann die Hüter nächste Woche schon kein trainer mehr sein. So einfach ist das. Aber man hat schon das Gefühl, dass schon relativ viel Bescheidenheit, aber auch Coolness herrscht in dem Verein. Er hat es schon geschafft, Österreicher eine homogene Einheit zu schaffen, also zu bilden. Weil du hast schon viele Charaktere in dieser Truppe, aber die folgen ihm. Und das ist schon eine Aufgabe. Monaco ist nicht so ein einfaches Pflaster, weil du hast keinen Druck, kaum Medien, 5000 Zuschauer im Durchschnitt. Und davon immer 3.000, 4.000 größte Fans. So dass es schon auch zum Eigentor führen kann. Weil wenn die Ergebnisse nicht stimmen, dann ist der Eigentümer nicht weit weg. Und auch Fürst Albert, der größte Fan der Monaco-Gassen. Und dann können die auch sehr schnell konsequent werden. Aber Rütter bis jetzt hat richtig gut geschafft. Nicht nur rein ergebnistechnisch, sondern auch von der Spielweise. Man sieht schon eine attraktive Spielweise. Ich schaue sehr gerne die Spiele von Monaco an, weil sie halt wie in der Bundesliga-Mannschaft agieren. Sehr offensiv, schwache Abwehr und dafür ist der Spektakel garantiert.
Moment mal, schwache Abwehr? Monaco hat doch erst drei Gegentreffer.
In der Liga, ja.
Ja, ach so, okay.
Sie haben sich auf jeden Fall stabilisiert und auch personifiziert, sag ich mal, von Tilo Kera, der schon verdient hätte, wieder von einem gewissen Herrn Lagnisbann berufen zu werden, irgendwann mal.
Das finde ich jetzt aber eine Sache spannend, Alexi. Du sagst, das ist ein Problem, dass da so wenig Druck herrscht an anderen Standorten, auch in der Bundesliga. Gibt es ja auch so Vereine, wo man damit dann erst mal irgendwie in Ruhe arbeiten kann. Aber du siehst es eher als Nachteil, dass da irgendwie kein Druck von außen von den Medien kommt. Wie kommt es?
Wie gesagt, weil das Duo mit dem Fürsten und dem Eigentümer, die sagen nie irgendwas in der Presse, aber wenn die Ergebnisse nicht mehr stimmen, fangen wir mal nach Nico Kovac zum Beispiel, dann wird konsequent gehandelt. Das ist halt im Hintergrund. Aber die lassen ihn in Ruhe arbeiten. Das ist schon für ihn sehr angenehm, sodass er seinen Spielstil entwickeln kann und sodass jetzt die Ergebnisse stimmen. Aber drei, vier Ergebnisse in Folge, die dann schlecht werden sollten, im Herbst oder im Winter, dann kann es sehr schnell unruhig werden. Aber tagtäglich, dass er in Ruhe arbeiten kann, ist natürlich ein Vorteil. Dass man aber zu Hause so eine Stimmung hat wie auswärts, ist schon ein Nachteil wiederum.
Hat jemand von euch zufällig das Heimspiel gegen Barca gesehen? Weil das konnte ich nicht verfolgen, weil das Monaco ja auch gewonnen hat. Und war das dann auch ein folgerichtiger Sieg? War ja die erste Niederlage für Flick. Das war ja noch kaum, haben wir hier in der Ligatur darüber gesprochen, dass Hansi Flick nie wieder ein Spiel verlieren wird mit Barca. Ungefähr so müssen wir es damals gesagt haben, anders kann ich mir das gar nicht vorstellen. Direkt dann haben sie verloren, wahrscheinlich um uns zu ärgern. War das auch verdient, diese 2-1-Aussicht von Monaco?
Bei aller Objektivität, ja. Der Ausschlag war natürlich bei Barca, dass die wohl zwei wichtigsten Spieler mit ihr mal, nämlich Ter Stegen und Lewandowski, grauenhaft waren. Also Ter Stegen war wie in der Nationalmannschaft früher, oder fast bis heute noch. Also man hat das Gefühl, dass er nicht gut drauf war. Auch in der Luft hat er immer wieder daneben gegriffen, hatte vom Auslaufen her nicht das gute Timing. Lewandowski hat, glaube ich, ein einziges Mal aufs gegenehrliche Tor geschossen, oder nicht mal. Also ihm hat die Mittelmeerluft da nicht gut getan. Das Stadion war ausnahmsweise ausverkauft. Man muss auch nicht vergessen, dass der Verein geradet sein 100-jähriges feiert, sodass die Spieler gut besucht sind. Das hielt vielleicht auch bei der guten Form von Monaco. Aber vom rein spielerischen war es schon verdient, auch in der Höhe 2-1, dass Monaco die drei Punkte einfährt am ersten Spielgang.
Es gab auch eine frühe rote Karte, sehr vermeidbar von Eric Garcia gewesen. Wenn du das schon in der zehnten Minute in Unterzahl bist, dann geht das schon dann schnell seine Bahnen so.
Silo Kera hat es übrigens nicht geschafft, Alexi. Hier gerade hot news.
Ja, dann ist gerade der Karte rausgekommen.
Ja, Plastik ist dabei, Hauptsache.
Wie ihr das alles nebenher schafft, aber gut, okay, alles klar. Ich sehe das schon. Gibt es denn noch Spieler, die man besonders herauskehren muss bei Monaco? Also jenseits der, die wir quasi aus der Bundesliga kennen, die du schon genannt hast?
Auf der einen Seite hast du natürlich die erfahrenen Spieler wie Alex Golovin, der immer noch da ist, der vom Stadion nach Hause fünf Minuten Gehfuss hat und immer am Tufus kräht, weil er gar nicht angesprochen wird. Das ist schon auf dem Niveau herrlich. Und so Newcomer, die haben sich schon klug verstärkt im Sommer, die Monacoisten mit Lamine Camara. Dann sind sie in der Erlese vom FC Metz. Der soll so der neue Zakaria werden, der neue Yusufo Fanah, der jetzt zum AC Milan gewechselt ist. Die Schwachstelle ist im Tor, weil Philipp Grün ist ein guter, aber kein Weltklasse Torwart. Er profitiert gerade von der Verletzung von Majetski. Er soll aber wieder Torwart Nummer 2 werden. Und im Sturm, da bin ich sehr gespannt. Also, Mbolo gefällt mir überhaupt nicht. Er trifft ja nichts. Er ist eher ein guter Vorlagengeber, aber er ist nicht effizient. Also, Monaco sollte es Probleme geben im Kampf um den Titel. Dann sehe ich ihn im Sturm, weil mit Balogun und Mbolo haben wir zwei Stürmer, die kein Selbstvertrauen haben und auch die Effizienz stimmt nicht richtig. Und da hat man Benyedea, der Kapitän, nicht ersetzen können. Und das könnte zum Verängnis werden, mittelfristig zumindest.
Gut, aber allein die Perspektive zu haben, dass es hier vielleicht mal wieder Konkurrenten für PSG geben würde, über die wir nach dem, was du da angedeutet hast, vielleicht auch bald mal widersprechen müssen. Da war es schon wieder… Also irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, du hast Luis Enrique durch die Blume kritisiert. Aber das machen wir demnächst mal. Lasst mal in die Premier League schauen, Uli. Und wenn du magst, würde ich gerne mit dir über Liverpool sprechen.
Ja.
Denn das war ja so vielleicht nicht zu erwarten, dass die mit zwei Gegentoren nach sechs Spieltagen an der Tabelle Spitze drohen. Punkt vor City ist eng. Aber wie hat denn das Arne Slot geschafft, diesen Übergang von Jürgen Klopp zu ihm zu managen?
Also erstmal, indem er gar nicht so extrem viel ändert, das ist ihm auch ganz, ganz wichtig. Das betont er permanent, dass er schon– ich sage jetzt mal– weitestgehend an der Basis angeknüpft hat. Es gibt ja jetzt nicht so viele Gründe, großartig viel zu ändern. Mit aber dem Unterschied, dass vor allen Dingen im Spielaufbau Liverpool etwas kontrollierter spielt. Das bedeutet, weit weniger schnell ins Absolut. Also es war immer so bei Klopp in der vergangenen saison, dass es nochmal so was wie ein Rückbesinnen auf die absolute Anfangszeit war. Das heißt, so schnell wie möglich gar nicht aufbauen, sondern schnell vertikal werden, also kontern ohne zu kontern sozusagen. Und es war letzte saison ganz oft so, dass das so hoch ging, so schnell, in so einem Tempo, dass es entweder den Gegner einfach völlig überrannt hat, was oft genug funktioniert hat oder aber dafür gesorgt hat, dass sie teilweise dann selbst den Kopf verloren haben in dieser Schnelligkeit und dann halt selbst den Konter zu haben waren. Und Slot hat jetzt darauf Wert gelegt oder scheint darauf Wert zu legen, auch wenn er das gar nicht so genau zugibt. Aber das ist das, was ich rausfinde, wenn ich die Spiele schaue, dass es etwas mehr Ballzirkulation geben darf, soll, dass man eher den Gegner auch mal ins Pressing einlädt, ganz klassisch, um dann durch die Reihen zu spielen. Aber auch noch nicht mal so zwingend. Und vor allen Dingen auf die Abstände achtet, bevor man den aufbaut oder wie man aufbaut. Und das ist so ein wesentlicher Unterschied, dass nicht immer alles so extrem schnell gehen muss. Das sorgt manchmal dafür, dass die Passagen, weil sie nicht ganz so unterhaltsam zu sehen sind wie unter Klopp, aber vor allen Dingen dann für etwaige Rückgewinnungen wieder ein bisschen besser gestaffelt stehen. Das ist, glaube ich, das wesentliche Merkmal, wenn man jetzt eine Veränderung rausarbeiten müsste. Ansonsten ist es schon so, dass rein Pressing strukturell vieles noch erinnert an die Jürgen-Klopp-Zeit. Es ist auch so, dass Arne Slot weitestgehend mit einer Elf spielt, also, sagen wir mal, sehr, sehr wenig rotiert. Auch da denkt er laut drüber nach, dass er immer wieder– macht das sowieso die ganze Zeit schon in seiner Amtszeit– querverweise auf seine Feyenoord-Zeit gibt. Das habe ich bei der Feyenoord auch so gemacht und sagte dann sofort immer, also mir ist übrigens klar, dass hier ist nicht Feyenoord. Das wird schon etwas schwieriger. Aber das macht er ganz gerne, dass er sagt, ich habe das da auch weitestgehend gemacht. Das war energetisch kein Problem für die Jungs. Und ich glaube, gerade in der Defensive vertraut er auch niemandem sonst. In der Offensive wird das irgendwann mal anders aussehen, wenn Chiesa eine Zeit da ist, wenn Gagbo möglicherweise mal etwas stabiler wird zum Beispiel. Dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es da leicht anders wird. Und das ist ja auch so, dass die Spieler, die da jetzt sind, einfach immer mal wieder eine Verletzung hatten.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch überlegt, ob wir jetzt schon über Liverpool sprechen oder ob wir uns das quasi für eine der nächsten Ligaturen aufsparen. Der Grund dafür ist folgende. Ipswich, Brentford, United, dann Niederlage gegen Nottingham, Bournemouth, Wolverhampton, aber auch auswärts bei Milan gewonnen und jetzt zu Hause gegen Bologna. Also was ich damit sagen will, ist, man hat jetzt nicht unbedingt gegen die absoluten Schwergewichte in der Liga gespielt.
Boah, größer Diss gegen Manchester United, aber genauso was er rausgespielt hat.
Entschuldigung, ja, also von dem spür habe ich was gesehen, deswegen kann ich das mit Vorredner bezogen sagen.
Ich habe mir auch vorgeschlagen, über United eventuell zu sprechen, aber es ist halt immer dasselbe über United. Das ist auch so langweilig, weil wir reden immer das Gleiche.
Ja, das machen wir ja bestimmt auch, und das tut mir ja auch leid für alle United-Fans, aber da tut sich ja wirklich gar nichts. Es geht weder nach vorne noch nach hinten. Aber für wie groß hältst du denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das jetzt eine Overreaction ist und Arne Slot da auch ein bisschen spiepern kann? Glück ist zu viel, aber das hat, glaube ich, schon ganz gut gepasst, wie man gestartet ist in die saison.
Ja, es hat sich gar nichts geändert an der Einschätzung, was Liverpool selbst betrifft und was aber auch deren Platz in der Liga betrifft. Ich glaube, die sind die dritte Kraft, mit einigem Abstand sogar zu 1 und 2. Das ist jeweils ein eigener Kosmos, da würde ich immer noch City haben. Arsenal ist aber wieder näher herangekommen, behaupte ich. In der saison gefallen sie mir gar nicht mehr so gut. Was jetzt so spielerisches betrifft, weil sie manchmal Dinge verschleppen. In England diskutiert viel das Wort Dark Arts, also die Spielverzögerungen und so, wie sie alle heißen. Da sind manchmal Elemente drin bei Arsenal, die gefallen mir nicht. Also aus ästhetischen Gründen, aber sie sind natürlich absolut sinnvoll, verstehe ich.
Also Teitspiel ist damit gemeint. So wie der Torhüter in der Nachspielzeit ein fiktives Beispiel im Champions-League-Spiel einfach den Oberschenkel hält.
Genau, die Amy-Martin-Sesierung der Premier League. Der ist die Nummer eins. Witzigerweise geht jeder Artikel mit Amy Martinez los, der diesbezüglich irgendwas untersucht hat. Amy Martinez Shit-Housery ist da das Stichwort. Ja, genau, Spiel verzögern, Bälle irgendwo schnell links aus Versehen wegstupsen, damit es nicht weitergeht. Generell, gerade jetzt in der Phase, in der Ödegaard nicht da ist, einfach die Netto-Spielzeit unten halten. Es gibt kein Team, das so lange wartet mit Spielfortsetzungen wie Arsenal, weil sie können das ganz gut aus einem Nicht-Rhythmus Rhythmus entwickeln und anderen Teams nicht so gut. Links- und Rechts-Bumps, wenn der Schiedsrichter nicht hinschaut. Beeinflussung des Schiedsrichters. Da ist ja Ahteta der Grund, warum die Premier League-Schiedsrichter stärker durchgreifen sollen. Wenn der Schiedsrichter meckert, ihm sofort gelb geben, das war ja die– also man sagt das zumindest– Initialzündung für diese etwas stärkere Ahndung, der nicht eingehaltenen Vorbildfunktionen an der Seitenlinie, weil Ahteta das so extrem macht. Dann gab es hier gegen City die Diskussionen, dass Arsenal den Spieler sehr viel provoziert haben sollen. Ich möchte aber auch anfügen, das war von der anderen Seite nicht so wenig, aber das ist etwas, was man Arsenal immer vorgeworfen hat. Sie seien sehr soft, das ist weg. Die sind nicht mehr soft, sondern die sind richtig abgezockt. Ich finde, dass sie sich in dem Punkt sehr ernst zu nehmen entwickelt haben. Deshalb sind die Nummer zwei. Aber jetzt einen ganz großen Bogen zurückzufinden zu Liverpool. Ich habe die sehr klar auf der drei. Ich finde, dass das, wie Slot aufgebaut ist, sehr viel von einzelnen Spielern verlangt. Das braucht brutale Laufleistungen von Grafenberg, von Sobozda, auch von McAllister, der ja meinig gestern getroffen hat, wenn ich das richtig erinnere. Ich habe nur nebenbei die Konferenz laufen lassen. Das ist schon extrem, was die zu arbeiten haben. Die werden Themen kriegen, die auch im Boulevard interessant werden. Wenn sie sich jetzt nicht bald mit Salah, mit Van Dijk und Trent Alexander-Arnold eidingen über Vertragsverlängerungen, dann wird das ungut werden. Dann müssten sie eventuell einen echten Umbruch einleiten, der ja de facto eigentlich schon angefangen wurde. Letzte saison mit Mittelfeld ging nur sehr viel schneller abgeschlossen, als man sie es vorgestellt hat, weil einfach sowas sehr gut funktioniert hat mit Gallister und auch Curtis Jones große Schritte gemacht hat und auch Harvey Elliott. Aber die dritte Kraft, das ist genau da, wo sie hingehören. Ich glaube, da würde ich fast einen Tausender setzen drauf, dass das so kommt.
Mach es mal lieber bitte nicht.
Was nicht, aber nur mal klarzumachen, wie sicher ich mit bin.
Dann habe ich nur noch eine Frage zu Liverpool und zwar, wir wissen ja, wie Jürgen Klopp nach außen hin kommuniziert und wir wissen auch, wie er vom Beginn an da angekommen ist. Wie schlägt sich im Vergleich dazu, Arne Slott?
Sehr gut, finde ich. Also mal die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, er ist sehr offen, so ähnlich wie Klopp auch. Er lässt nicht ganz so viel Einblick zu, aber es ist schon offen diskutiert, die Punkte, die er dann so hat, der so sieht. Ich habe mir auch sagen lassen, intern, dass er super beliebt ist, weil er– anders als Klopp– sehr, sehr viel seine Mitarbeiter stärkt. Er lässt so eine Art Supervisor, er lässt sehr, sehr viel zu, dass die Mitarbeiter viel mit den Spielern, was eigene Ideen betrifft, arbeitet, aber auch diesen sehr fortschrittlichen Ansatz weitergeht. Die Videositzungen sollen super sein. Also es ist so, dass es sie kürzer hält zum Teil, aber dafür mehr öfter. Und die sollen sehr, sehr gut ankommen. Und er muss so eine ganz eigene Art von Humor haben, die in England nicht verkehrt aufgehoben ist, sodass er auch intern echt beliebt ist. Ehrlicherweise ist es immer schwierig. Das letzte Gespräch habe ich geführt irgendwann Mitte, Ende September. Und wenn die da schon sagen würden, ganz ehrlich, der Alte, der hat sie nicht alle, dann wäre es natürlich auch schwierig. Aber was ich jetzt von intern gehört habe, ist das wirklich positiv aufgenommen. Ich traue mich schon zu zu unterscheiden, ob das jetzt ein wir sagen dir jetzt nur nicht, dass er sie nicht alle hat ist, oder ein wirklich aktives Loben, weil sie ganz, weil bei ein paar Dinge da sind, die sie wirklich ganz gut finden. Und öffentlich finde ich auch, macht das echt sehr ordentlich. Bis auf diese Feyenoord-Vergleiche, die werden ihm eines Tages auf die Füße fallen. Aber ansonsten ist das wirklich sehr, sehr ordentlich. Ich glaube, recht viel. Du hast schon gesagt, das Programm spielt schon eine echte Rolle. Das hat ihn smooth reinkommen lassen. Aber er macht es gut.
Sehr gut. Wir werden es weiter im Blick behalten. Arne Slot bei Liverpool. Und wenn Liverpool die dritte Pracht in der Premier League ist, das vielleicht auch, dann frage ich mich, Mario, was denn dann Juve ist. Also die Tabelle sagt aktuell, Rang 2. Die Tabelle sagt auch, Tore, die man kassiert hat, 0 Spiele bisher, 8 Spiele, 3 Mal hat man schon 0 zu 0 gespielt. Ich habe den Eindruck, Thiago Motta, der trainer von Juve, hat einen Fokus auf Defensive. Aber die Frage ist, auf welchem Rang würden wir sie dann einsortieren, langfristig, Juve?
Ich würde sie tatsächlich, wenn es so weitergeht, auf jeden Fall als Contender für die Meisterschaft, die das ja auch schon wieder reinwerfen, weil er es auch geschafft hat, Rotation jetzt mit Doppelbelastung gut hinzubekommen. Und ich würde aber auch tatsächlich das mit der Defensivarbeit so ein bisschen in Klammern setzen wollen, denn es sind ausgewählte Spiele, in denen er sich sehr auf die Defensive fokussiert. Und was ganz lustig war, ich war am Dienstag in Stuttgart im Stadion und stand dann noch nach den Interviews da ein bisschen rum, und dann hat Carasor im Interview mit dem KlubTV gesagt, als nächstes kommt es dann Juve, die werden sich hinten reinstellen und kontern. Und dann dachte ich, wenn ihr euch da mal nicht täuscht, weil dann kommt das Spiel gegen Leipzig, wo sich Marco Rose gedacht hat, im Ball haben wir nicht so viele Ideen, dann kontern wir doch im eigenen Stadion. Juve war sehr dominant, hat sich dann tatsächlich einmal auskontern lassen. Aber wie sie da dann zurückgekommen sind, mit ihrem besten Verteidiger verloren, Bremer, nach drei, vier Minuten. In der zehnten Minute müssen sie noch mal wechseln, weil Nico Gonzales das Problem mit dem Oberschenkel hat. Dann kommen sie wieder zurück ins Spiel, nach der Halbzeit kriegen einen nächsten Nackenschlag. Der Torwart fliegt vom Platz. Sie machen zu zehnt weiter und der Freistoß aus der Situation führt dann zum Elfmeter. Leipzig geht 2-1 in Führung und dann drehen sie in Leipzig. Sie sind ja auch immer noch Dritter der Deutschen Bundesliga. Sie drehen das Spiel auswärts noch. Mota verbindet das, was wir auch– ich verstehe auch, dass Carra so das, glaube ich, gesagt hat. Das war unter aller Leak wie viele Jahre so. Und eigentlich, ehrlicherweise, war Juve selbst in den Jahren, wo wir jetzt ein bisschen mit der verklärten Sicht an del Piero denken, war Juve auch nie das Team aus Italien, das für großen Hurra-Fußball stand. Juve war immer die Mannschaft, bei der ging es halt drum. Geht bei allen drum, aber bei Juve umso mehr. Wir gewinnen halt das Spiel und wenn es 1-0 ist. Mota verbindet das, was man zum Beispiel dann gesehen hat, im Spitzenspiel gegen Napoli. Das war 1 und 0-0. Das durfte sich begleiten als Kommentator. Irgendwie hat man nach 10 Minuten gesehen, sowohl Konter bei Napoli als auch Mota bei Juve haben die Marschroute vorgegeben. Also ihr dürft mal in die gegnerische Hälfte, aber mir ist ganz, ganz wichtig, dass ihr wisst, wo ihr wieder hinlauft, wenn wir vorne den Ball verlieren. Und das hast du bei den Spielern wirklich übertritt, mittellinie, dann waren es manchmal nur zwei Spieler, die trotz einer aussichtsreichen Kontersituation da mitgelaufen sind. Das war ganz, ganz schwerer Kost.
Und das hast du kommentieren dürfen, schrecklich gesagt. Wie ist das als Kommentator, wenn einem das bewusst wird, so in der zehnten Minute?
Ich hatte Michi Hofmann dabei, der sehr gut aufgelegt war. Michi Hofmann kann man Zeit immer gut füllen.
Da wird hier auch eine Runde genickt. Okay, alles klar. Sehr gut.
Ich grüße gehen wir los. Ja, und auf jeden Fall verbindet er das. Also er hat das bewahrt, weil er wäre doof gewesen, um zu sagen, dass das defensive Abläufe, die unter Allegri einstudiert waren, wenn er die komplett über den Haufen wirbt, also Juve versteht es nach wie vor engmaschig und gut sortiert zu stehen. Und hat aber nach vorne hin schon einen viel progressiveren Ansatz als das jemals zuvor in den letzten Jahren, was ich von Juve gesehen habe, der Fall war. Also sie kommen meistens von 4-2-3-1 daher. Wenn sie mit dem Ball spielen, dann hast du mit einem Neuzugang Cob Maynard auf der 10 ein, der sehr spielintelligent ist. Ich glaube, bei Atalanta hat ihn vielleicht der ein oder andere schon mal beobachtet. Wir haben Kenan Yildiz über die linke Seite, der gestern gegen Leipzig ein bisschen plass war, aber der ansonsten schon in der saison gezeigt hat, dass ihm auch das Vertrauen, das er von Mota bekommt und die regelmäßige Spielzeit, das war in der Ligri auch noch nicht so, dass ihm das auch hilft. Sie haben rechts ja Nico Gonzalez geholt, der dann verletzt runtergeht, aber dafür kommt dann Chico Concesao, den sie von Porto geholt haben, der dann gegen Leipzig auch noch das Siegtor macht. Einer, mit super viel Spielwitz, dem es auch mal gelingt, natürlich in der Situation im 1 gegen 1 aufzureißen. Was ich aber tatsächlich, welchen Namen ich hier einmal getroppt haben möchte, und vielleicht hören wir in ein paar Monaten immer mehr von ihm, das ist Andrea Campiaso. Der spielt meistens auf der linken Verteidigerposition, wenn man sich die Aufstellung anguckt in der App, und wenn man sich das Spiel anguckt, dann spielt er überall. Das hat fast sowas von Calla Fiori, Bastoni, Di Marco. Er schiebt ganz weit hoch. Er schiebt auch mal von der linken auf die er ist, nämlich beidfüßig. Er schiebt dann auch mal gerne durchs ganze Zentrum mit rüber. Dafür lässt sich eine Mittelfeldspieler in den Dreieraufbau fallen. Das ist von den Ideen her, die Motta da einbringt, schon so viel spannender anzusehen. Alles unter Allegri in den letzten Jahren. Ich glaube, ich habe selber auch ein kleines Problem mit Allegri. Ich habe den Namen schon zu oft gesagt. Aber Thiago Motta macht Spaß. Was man vor allem noch zusätzlich herausstellen sollte bei Juve, ist, dass die alte Dame insofern wirklich im neuen Gewand daherkommt, dass es endlich mal wieder Juve im wortwörtlichen Sinne ist. Es sind junge Spieler. Sie sind im ersten Spiel gegen Eindhoven zu Hause mit der im Schnitt jüngsten Mannschaft aller Zeiten in der Juve-Geschichte angetreten. Hinten rechts hat gegen Leipzig jetzt Savona seinen Champions-League-Debüt gefeiert. Da hätte man auch Danilo, den eigentlichen Kapitän, spielen lassen können. Im Mittelfeld kommt Douglas Lewis zum Beispiel, den man für eine ganze Menge Geld geholt hat. Immer wieder nur von der Bank, weil McKennie gerade noch mal über sich hinaus wächst, der auch bei dem einen Tor eine unfassbare Krätsche in der Vorbereitung defensiv macht und auch diese Dynamik, die ihm so auszeichnet, wieder entfaltet dann in die Tiefe. Und Fadjoli, der ja fast auch ein Jahr gesperrt war, das war die Geschichte mit Tonali, also weil wir es vorhin mit wetten hatten. Tut es nicht. Bitte nicht. Genau, und das ist bei Mota ist, wer gut trainiert und bei wem ich sehe, dass er das machen kann, der spielt auch, egal welcher Name er ist, ob er aus der eigenen Jugend kam oder ob es der ist, den wir für 50 Millionen aus der Premier League geholt haben. Und das war auch bei Juve schon nicht immer der Fall. Es war ein sehr konservativ geführter Verein auf allen Ebenen gewesen, wo schon viel auch die Credits eine Rolle gespielt haben in der Mannschaftszusammensetzung. Und das hat Mota aufgebrochen. Bislang sieht das sehr, sehr gut aus. Und um auf die Eingangsfrage, die ich ja schon auch mit als Titelanwärter beantwortet habe, ist es trotzdem auch deswegen so schwer, weil wir ja trotzdem nicht immer noch Inter, die der Top-Favorit sind. Wir haben aber Napoli mit Konter, der nur einen Wettbewerb richtig spielen muss. Und das, ja, Uli nickt auch schon, das hat er auch schon in anderen Ligen gezeigt, dass das genau seine Sache ist. Von daher höchst spannend. Aber ich glaube, der ein oder andere deutsche Journalist, Journalistin wird sich noch vielleicht darüber wundern, wenn er Juve dann das erste Mal wirklich sieht und das Cattinaccio auf dem Zettel durchstreichen muss.
Kannst du dann bitte nachher, Max, einfügen, die Stellungnahme von Christian Bernhardt, dem Allegri-Versteher dazu, weil wir das können wir so nicht stehen lassen.
Ich vermute, dass die Unterlassungserklärung jetzt schon raus ist von ihm an mich. Gehe ich von aus, ja. Aber der Eindruck täuscht dann nicht, Mario, die Serie A ist gerade eine unheimlich heiße Liga, weil wenn man sich anguckt, mit allem, was du eben gesagt hast und die bisher sechs gespielten Spiele, das könnte eine brutal interessante saison werden von der Spitze her.
Ja, und dann weißt du ja immer noch nicht, was diese Mannschaften auf den Übergangsplätzen machen. Also von der Roma hat man da ja noch gar nicht gesprochen. Oder ein paar Überraschungsmannschaften, die halt dann auch, die werden nicht unter den ersten 3-4 einlaufen. Na gut, Atalanta hast du auch noch. Also das ist so, ich glaube, es sind halt viele Spiele, also die Leistungsdichte an der Spitze ist extrem nah beieinander. Und ich glaube, entscheidend im Meisterrennen wird dann sein, wie halt die Teams, die die Doppelbelastung oder Dreifachbelastung haben, dann damit umgehen. Das hat in Sargi schon mal in der saison das Genick gebrochen. Mota hat das halt in der Form so das erste Mal. Der konnte letztes Jahr mit Bologna einfach so gemütlich auch aufzocken. Und jetzt sind auch Samples, da ist es relativ klein, er hat jetzt zwei Champions-League-Wochen gehabt. Kann man da noch nicht komplett irgendwie sein Fazit ziehen. Aber ich würde es mir weiter so gerne angucken.
Also auf jeden Fall und auch schön, dass quasi einfach nur keine Doppelbelastung bedeutet. Gemütlich aufzocken. Hat sich gemütlich mit Bologna in die Champions-League gespielt, wie wir es erwartet haben. So kam das ja. Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt. Also Serie A total interessant. Ich sehe meistens nur Ergebnisse, weil klar, ich habe das ganze Wochenende über viel zu tun. Aber ja, spannend. Und spannend ist auch La Liga. Aus ganz verschiedenen Gründen nie. Wie viel werden wir über Sportliches reden jetzt gleich?
Das ist die Sache. Eben wurde jeweils ein Club als Thema mitgebracht. Ich bringe gleich mal zwei Clubs mit. Zumindest das Duell dieser beiden Clubs. Es war der derby in Madrid, und damit meine ich nicht Rallo gegen Leganes. Ich meine natürlich das andere 1-1, Atletico Real Madrid. Und zumindest das, was vor, während und auch ein bisschen nach dem Derby passiert ist. Viele haben es ja mitbekommen. Es kam auch unter anderem zu einer Spielunterbrechung. Schon vor dem Derby hatte sich so ein bisschen angebahnt, oh, das ist mehr als am brodeln. Da haben Atletico-Fans aus sozialen Netzwerken aufgerufen, Maske zu tragen, um dann ungestraft ihre Meinung äußern zu dürfen.
Oh Gott.
Es gab Aufrufe, Handy in den Taschen zu lassen, damit ja keine Aufnahme nach außen dringt, wo man vielleicht das eine oder andere raus hören könnte. Manche Accounts haben sogar noch mal diese Bilder mit dieser Vinicius-Puppe vor ein, zwei Jahren noch mal gebracht und so weiter. Also da schon mal sehr viel am brodeln. Immerhin dann, das Derby an sich ist ja bis zur 60. Minute, bis es dann eskaliert ist, wirkte fast ein bisschen descaffeinado, sagt der Spanier, also entcoffeinierter. Verlief sogar ein bisschen ruhiger von der Atmosphäre, auch von der Spielweise bei der Teams natürlich auch. Für Ordnung wenig Risiko, erst mal abwarten, eher irgendwie mit dem Punkt zufrieden sein. Also war da jetzt noch nicht wahrzunehmen, dass es da zu gewissen Beleidigungen kam. Und auch, ich hatte auch einen Mann vor Ort in Marlond, der hat jetzt auch nicht groß oder viele Masken gesehen, eher noch vor dem Stadion als dann im Stadion selbst und eben nichts groß wahrgenommen. Aber dann ist es eben in der 64. Minute passiert, da hatte dann Vignices Juniors Flanke gebracht auf Militao im Strafe und der trifft dann zum 1-0. Und da ist es dann beim Torjubel von Thibaut Coutoix, danach dann eskaliert. Thibaut Coutoix ist ja auch Ex-Atletico-Spieler, hat eine Vergangenheit. Wir haben sich dann umgedreht, auf den Platz zu den Athletico-Fans und so gemacht, so, ah, vamos, mit einem lachenden Gesicht und dann diese Geste, vamos. Vamos heißt nur, auf geht's, los. Nicht viel mehr, das war jetzt keine Beleidigung. Danach flogen dann einige Gegenstände auf den Platz. Feuerzeuge, Flaschen, auch eine Tüte, wo ein bisschen Müll drin war, was dann geräumt werden durfte. Und da hat dann der Schiedsrichter konsequent entschieden, dass das Spiel unterbrechen werden sollte. Den trainern zuerst informiert, dann wurden dann eben 15, 20 Minuten ausgesetzt. Und ja, danach sollten sich die Gemüter dann langsam beruhigen. Auch Simone und ein paar Spieler von Athletico haben da auf ihre Fans eingedrungen. Die Fans waren dann auch teilweise schon in den Innenraum vorgedrungen oder einfach runtergeklettert von den Tribünen. Also da einfach schon mal sehr unschöne Bilder und kann man als Waldeskalation bezeichnen, weil es sind ja trotzdem Wurfgeschosse bei Ciringito hatten danach rausgefunden, dass ein Polizist sogar noch ein Messer festgestellt hat bei einem der Fans, die da mit Maske dann oder vermummt einfach irgendwas getrieben haben. Von dem her mal wieder Unschönes vom Derby Matrilenio.
Und wie ging das dann weiter? Also am Ende war es ja dann ein später Ausgleich von Atletico, aber es gab ja glaube ich auch eine irre Nachspielzeit und noch einen Platzverweis hinten raus. Also wie war dann das Ende des Spiels und dann wie wird denn das jetzt behandelt? Weil es ja nicht zum ersten Mal, dass wir solche Probleme haben.
Ja, also erst mal rein sportlich nach wie gesagt 15, 20 Minuten ging es weiter, weil die Zeit nicht gleich sofort gestoppt wurde. Gab es eine lange Nachspielzeit von 8 bis 9 Minuten, auch wenn gar nicht mehr so viel sportlich jetzt passiert ist hinsichtlich Unterbrechungen. Realne hat natürlich gehofft aufs Verwalten und den Konter setzen und Endrick hätte einmal noch abspielen können auf Bellingen, dann wäre es vielleicht 2-0 gestanden. Aber so geht das unentschieden erst mal auch voll in Ordnung. Sehr ausgeglichene Zahlen hinsichtlich Fahls und Abschlüssen. Und so hatte dann eben Angril Correa noch einmal ausgenutzt, dass er an Antonio Rüdiger das Abseits-Fall nicht zuschnappt. Also so kam Atletico da noch zum 1-1, war dann auch mehr drin im Spiel und so weiter. Also da über den Punkt selbst muss man hier nicht groß streiten. Das geht soweit in Ordnung, ne? Nur halt, ja, ist jetzt mal wieder der Fall gewesen, dass da Atletico selbst aufgefallen ist. Wir reden ja nicht nur über diverse rassistische Vorfälle irgendwie gegen Winnius, das war ja auch schon, ich glaube, in der letzten Rückrunde, da wurde auch Nico Williams rassistisch beleidigt, auch so aus dieser gleichen Ecke. Und da hatte jetzt dann auch mal auf der Pressekonferenz nach, wenn spielt Diego Simeone auch mal diese gewisse Gruppe, mehr oder weniger angesprochen, da geht es dann immer um diese Ultras namens Frente Atletico. Die werden seit Jahren noch vom Verein geduldet, sind durchaus bekannt als rechtsextrem, aber irgendwie dürfen sie weiter noch als Gruppe stattfinden im Stadion, hatten schon diverse Vorfälle. Jetzt ist es halt mal wieder eskaliert, wo dann auch Simeone sagte, von wegen man muss eine Entscheidung finden für diese Gruppe. Auf der anderen Seite meinte Simeone aber auch, er forderte eine Strafe für die Täter, die die Gegenstände werfen. Auf der anderen Seite sagte aber ein Diego Simeone, er sagte aber auch, Strafe aber auch für den, der provoziert. Ui, da kann er sich schon mal den Urlaub buchen in den nächsten Jahren, unter den ein oder anderen Pausen. Wie gesagt, das von Thibaut Couture überhaupt als Provokation, groß abzuhandeln. Klar, muss er nicht zwingend machen, sich umdrehen und Warmus zu machen, aber es war jetzt auch nicht, dass er da hier x-beliebige Beleidigungen einfügen gesagt hat und ein bisschen… Also was ist eine Provokation? Das ist jetzt so ein Torjubel, wirklich eine klare Provokation. Muss man sich davon als Fan so angestachelt fühlen, dass man dann irgendwie in den Innenraum stürmt und so weiter. Also da ist mal wieder gefühlte Täter-Opfer-Umkehr, sagte auch Anschlotti danach vom Wegen her. Es geht hier nicht um die angebliche Provokation von Couture, sondern es geht darum, dass hier Gewalt verhübt wurde, dass die Leute Gegenstände reingeworfen haben und, und, und. Also da wieder unschönes Immerhin jetzt. Die vermutlich erste Konsequenz oder einzige, die ich bisher wahrgenommen habe, ist, dass es jetzt zu einer teilweiseen Sperre kommen wird bei Atletico, dass aber auch nicht das komplette Stadion, auch nicht die komplette Kurve hinterm Tor, sondern diese jeweiligen Blöcke, zwei Blöcke, wo eben diese Ultras sind, für drei Heimspiele gesperrt werden. Atletico kann noch Berufungen einlegen, aber das ist jetzt so die erste Konsequenz, ohne dass ich jetzt mitgenommen habe, dass zum Beispiel die Fremde-Athletico endlich mal gesperrt werden. Wir auch. Zum Beispiel die Ultrasur bei Real Madrid. Die sind ja schon vor zehn Jahren, glaube ich. Auch Borja Snoj bei Barca schon vor langer Zeit verbannt worden vom Verein. Nur Atleti hält irgendwie noch, warum auch immer, an denen fest.
Ja, ich meine, Kollektivstrafen natürlich auch immer ein schwieriges Thema. Aber weil du das jetzt so in Verbindung gebracht hast zu Ultrasur und eben auch der Barca-Fallen-Gruppierung– ich traue mich, den Namen auszusprechen– waren es denn damals ähnliche Gründe auch tatsächlich? Also gibt es einfach rechtsextreme oder rechte Fan-Gruppierungen, die sich organisieren? Ist das ein Problem in Spanien?
Ja, haben wir ja schon oft auch gesehen, dass es da durchaus noch rassistische Tendenzen in der Gesellschaft gibt, wo es nicht nur bei Atletico oder beim FC Valencia, sondern in vielen Fangemeinden noch zu Vorfällen kommt oder auch kam und das auch nicht nur gegen Wien, sondern auch viele andere Spieler. Die Ultrasur selbst, da gibt es auch ein paar Bilder, Symbole, wo mal ein Arm oben war oder gewisse Nazisymbole. Selbst jetzt vor dem Derby hatten die Ultrasur, die es ja immer noch als Gruppe gibt, auch nochmal auf Instagram Post gemacht, wo dann beim Atletico-Logo irgendwie der David-Stern, also Judensymbol, dabei war. Warum? Auch dumm. Und Beuys was Neues auch durchaus für gewisse Tendenzen bekannt, auch wenn jetzt die letzten Vorfälle mit Flickei in Monaco und ich glaube in Paris, da gab es auch schon eine Strafe in der letzten Rückrunde, da hatte auch einer den Arm oben. Das würde jetzt nicht direkt auf diese Ultras-Gruppe zurückführen, aber es gibt durchaus generell in der spanischen Gesellschaft, wo wir ja auch schon öfter drüber geredet haben, da ein paar Probleme, wo vielleicht die Bildung auch ein bisschen nachlässt oder so. Aber es ist natürlich jetzt kein komplettes pauschales Problem in der Gesellschaft, aber wenn es halt vorkommt, dann ist es halt sehr, sehr auffällig dann.
Die Frente-Fahne hing auch ab und an mal in Düsseldorf. Da haben die auch eine Ruhlgruppe von Fortuna, gute Kontakte. Da wurde damals das auch einfach dann drüber hinweggegangen.
Also Grüße gehen erstmal raus an alle, die mir immer erzählen wollen, vor allem in den YouTube-Kommentaren. Fußball sei unpolitisch und man soll die Politik raushalten aus dem Stadion. Machen wir doch einfach ein Deal. Wenn die scheiß Nazis sich mal raushalten aus allen Stadien, dann denke ich drüber nach, ob wir den Rest auch unpolitisch machen. Vorher fand ich da überhaupt gar nichts. Aber führt denn das jetzt mal zu einer tiefer gehenden Diskussion? Weil wir müssen jetzt ja auch nicht so tun, als ob die Spanische Liga die einzige Liga oder Gesellschaft wäre, die dieses Problem hat. Es ist ein generelles Problem vieler Länder. Aber die Frage ist ja, wie geht man damit um? Also ändert sich da was in der Diskussion? Oder ist es so ähnlich? Wir haben ja über dieses Thema auch schon öfter hier gesprochen.
Ich glaube, man geht da sehr schlecht sogar mit um. Es gab noch rund vor dem Derby von einem anderen Verein ein passendes Beispiel. Da hatte Retafel Neuzugang Uce vor dem Spiel gegen Barcelona ein Interview bei BBC gegeben und seine ersten Liga-Erfahrungen gemacht. Vor allem ein bisschen Kritik an den Schiedsrichtern. Aber auch gesagt, die Fans beleidigen einen ständig mit. Rassistische Beleidigungen einfügen. Aber es wird nichts dagegen unternommen. Das schon mal krasse, ehrliche Worte. Der PR-Berater wird sich denken, oh mein Gott. Aber was noch eigentlich viel schlimmer danach war, war, dass Retafel-Präsident Ankhil Torres den Maulkorb verpasst hat. Er kann gar nicht wissen, was die Fans da sagen. Der hat quasi die Klappe zu halten. Da ist schon mal einer so ehrlich und offen und spricht ein Problem direkt an und wird dann so Maulkorb verpassen. Auch, was Vinicius in der Länderspielpause gesagt hat, wenn sich die Situation nicht ändert. Es ist zwar nur eine Minderheit in Spanien, aber wenn es sich nicht ändert, dann muss man auch darüber nachdenken, ob Spanien wirklich die WM stattfinden lassen sollte. Es ist ihm natürlich auch um die Ohren geflogen. Und alle nein, Spanien ist kein rassistisches Land, wo sich dann Medienfans dagegen stellt haben. Es geht immer nur natürlich um eine gewisse Minderheit, aber es ist halt irgendwie eine ziemlich große und verbreitete Minderheit. Und das ist bestimmt auch in Italien so. Aber in Spanien fällt das numerisch rein in der Anzahl an Vorfällen schon ziemlich oft auf, wo, wie gesagt, auch mal Nikko Williams, auch mal ein Chukwetze rassistisch beleidigt wurde und, und, und.
Ach, es ist einfach traurig. 1992 wollte Uli Hoeneß-Ruth Hülle zum FC Bayern holen, gemeinsam mit Karl-Heinz Rummenigge und Franz Beckenbauer. Und nach allem, was man weiß, er wollte sich da nicht mehr zu äußern, als ich versucht habe, das für FC Leipzig noch mal zu verifizieren, war damals der wesentliche Grund, dass seine Frau und er Bedenken hatten wegen der Ausländerfeindlichkeit in Deutschland. Da war ja gerade Rostock-Lichtenhagen und so weiter, die Anschläge, und dann hat er gesagt, ach, irgendwie lieber nicht. Nun ja, dann kommen wir zu wieder sportlichen Themen. Wir wollen noch unsere Awards vergeben, d.h. wieder MVP an Sang Hero und die Geschichte der Woche und springen dabei durch die Ligen. Alexi, du darfst sehr gerne mal loslegen. Du hast uns Bradley Bacula mitgebracht, der trotz seines arroganten trainers offenbar eine ganz gute Zeit hat.
Bradley Bacula ist in der Vor- und Mittelliga 1 sehr erfolgreich, hat schon sechs Treffer erzielt in dieser saison. Das war die Frage natürlich nach dem Abgang von Mbappé, wer sein Nachfolger wird. Offiziell gibt es keinen Nachfolger, weil da war man relativ diskret auf dem Transfermarkt, da ist es eher schwer zu ersetzen, wenn nicht unmöglich. Zumindest dem Mbappé vor zwei, drei, vier Jahren. Marcola ist wahnsinnig schnell in den Griff zu kriegen, weil er schnell ist, trinkreich und dribbelstark. Er muss noch ein bisschen an seiner Muskulatur arbeiten und dann ist er ein ganz großer. Aber er ist auch mannschaftsinnlicher, zum Beispiel als ein Sergent Abrey, also kann er wirklich ein großer werden. Das war natürlich vor einem Jahr die größte Überraschung, als er seinen Jugendverein UNATLIK lyonais für Paris saint-germain verließt. Dann dachten wir, er wird Baumspielzeit bekommen in der Hauptstadt. Aber Luis Enrique hat ihm seine Chance gegeben, hat sie genutzt. Mittlerweile ist auch Bacula sogar in der Nationalmannschaft gesetzt, weil Coman mehr verletzt als fit ist, weil Dembele immer seine Kollegen auch vergisst und schneller als der Ball ist. Und so spielt das in den Karten von Bacula. Bacula und Ulises könnten in der Zukunft die zwei großen Stars von der französischen Nationalmannschaft werden, auch nach dem bekannten Abgang der Nationalmannschaftskarriere Ende von Antoine Griezmann. Aber Bacula ist auf einem wirklich guten Weg und er ist einer der wenigen Lichtblicke bei Paris saint-germain in dieser noch jugend-saison.
Und was meinst du, wenn du sagst, er muss an seiner Muskulatur arbeiten? Also geht ihm irgendwann die Puste aus oder hast du Angst, dass er sich verletzt?
Ja, die Angst, dass er sich verletzt, weil er sehr flinke Beine hat, aber auch sehr dünne Beine. Und dann ist natürlich jeder harter Zweikampf für ihn schon. Jedes Mal haben die PSG-Verantwortlichen schon Angst, dass er sich verletzt. Aber er ist sehr seriös, er ist diszipliniert, legt sehr viel Wert auf seine Mahlzeiten, sodass er bisher wirklich vom Verletzungsbereich verschwunden wurde. Im Gegensatz zu Dembele zum Beispiel oder Coman. Und wenn ihn sein Körper in Ruhe lässt, dann kann er wirklich Weltklasse werden. Und hoffentlich auch irgendwann mal woanders spielen als bei PSG.
Und ich habe ehrlich gesagt von PSG jetzt gerade noch gar nichts gesehen in dieser saison. Barcula spielt ja auf dem linken Flügel.
Genau.
Miohany spielt aber nicht in der Mitte. Wer spielt? Also ich habe nur mitbekommen, dass er eben immer noch nicht so wirklich spielt. Wie ist eigentlich so die Dreierreihe vorne bei PSG?
Ja, die Einsatzzeiten von Colomoni sind größer in der Nationalmannschaft als im Verein. Ganz einfach. So dass er jetzt den Belé aus dem Kader gestrichen bei Arsenal am Dienstag. Nichtsdestotrotz blieb der Ex-Rankfutter auf der Bank. Also er hat keine Chance unter Lucien Ricke. Und Lucien Ricke spielt ohne richtige Neun, sondern falsche Neuner. Mal Asensio, mal Kangin Lee. Aber lange ist es her, als Brejmovic, Cavani da waren und richtig tolle Treue gaben, sogar Mbappé, auch wenn er nicht so gerne in der Mitte spielte. Aber Passo Bakula normalerweise links, Dembeler rechts und in der Mitte, dann wird immer wieder getauscht. Aber Colombo Ani hat keine Chance. Es kommt Saloramos, der ist gerade verletzt. Sobald er wieder fit ist, womöglich im November, dann wird der Portugiese wohl normalerweise Gesetz sein.
Ah, okay. Und jetzt muss ich doch noch eine Frage stellen. Sorry, aber ich habe dieses Video von Luis Enrique gesehen, wo er irgendetwas über Dembeler gesagt hat. Ich habe es aber nicht verstanden und ich hatte keine Zeit zu googeln, ich hatte keine Zeit, es mir zu übersetzen. Was ist da passiert?
Im Spiel gegen Rennes am letzten Freitag war Dembeler genauso mannschaftsdienlich wie Serge Navri gestern, nämlich gar nicht.
Du hast ja heute hier wirklich deine Shots mitgebracht, aber egal.
Die bringe ich immer mit, sonst hätte er mich vergessen. Dembeler hat zum Beispiel alles super gemacht, nur seine Ständigkeit und die generische Abwehr im Stich gelassen, sozusagen, und dann seine Kollegen der Mitte nicht bedient, sondern alleine gemacht. Und man weiß ja, wie schwach er ist im Abschluss. Das war schon in Dortmund so, in Barcelona und jetzt noch mehr bei PSG. So in diesem Bereich hat er sich keinen Zentimeter weiterentwickelt. Und das hat wirklich Lüsenricke entzührend. Dann gab es ein Gespräch am Tag danach, am Samstag, nach der Videositzung, und Dembeler hat die Kritik von Lüsenricke weder verstanden noch akzeptiert, sodass es zum Crash kam zwischen beiden. Und darauf folgenden hat Lüsenricke Dembeler aus dem Krader gestrichen. Aber am Sonntagabend ist er an der Côte d'Azur in der Allianz Riviera von Nizza wieder im Krader und so möglich von Beginn an dabei.
Okay, danke schön. Jetzt habe ich das auch verstanden. Dann schauen wir mal auf den MVP in der Premier League. Da wurde ein Vier-Tore-Mann vorgeschlagen. Ich vermute einfach mal, so wie ich dich kenne, Uli, ist nicht der einzige Grund, warum Cole Palmer jetzt hier genannt wird.
Ja, doch. Eigentlich ist er wahrscheinlich auch der einzige Grund, warum Jesse im Moment ganz okay unterwegs ist, wenn man es mal etwas überspitzt formulieren möchte. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich die Definition von Most Valuable Player. Das ist einfach so erstaunlich, wie wertvoll der Typ seit der saison 2023, seit seinem Wechsel vor etwas mehr als einem Jahr geworden ist. 43 Torbeteiligungen sind die meisten in der Premier League unter allen. Da sind ja ein paar, die extrem überperformen. Harland, Watkins, you name it. Und jetzt vier Tore innerhalb einer Hälfte zu machen, ist so noch nicht passiert. Das ist das Erstaunliche an diesem Cole Palmer. Der hat so etwas. Ich liebe diese positiv arroganten Spieler, die ja in England vornehmlich produziert werden. Und jetzt gerade diese jüngere Generation, da passiert das öfter. Man sagt ja immer über ihn, das ist dieser Spitzname, der auch irgendwie passt. Cole Palmer, weil es oft so wirkt, als würde einfach alles in Zeitlupe vor ihm ablaufen, bevor er dann aber völlig heiß läuft. Das ist nämlich das Erstaunliche, weil der manchmal so 20 Minuten im Spiel hat, wo du denkst, es ist nichts mehr zu tun, du kannst nichts mehr machen, egal was jetzt passiert, der nimmt jetzt den Ball und du weißt, was passiert, aber vergiss es, er wird es jetzt einfach machen. Und das ist wieder passiert jetzt am Wochenende gegen einen zugegebenermaßen, das war naiv gegen naiv, Brighton gegen Jersey, nur dass die einen das naive etwas physischer gestaltet haben und dann Brighton einfach schön hops genommen haben mit einer Sache, die Fabian Hütze dann in den Griff zu bekommen hat. Aber ich glaube, Karl Palmer hat es wirklich verdient, dass man ihn da nennt. Da ist die Frage noch, was dann letztlich wirklich die allerbeste Position ist, wenngleich er von überall wahnsinnig gut ist. Ich glaube, jetzt spielt er im Moment etwas mehr am Zentrum, weil Noni Madueke auf der rechten Seite spielt und weil Mareska sowieso sowas wie seine Startformation findet, was diesem FC Chelsea insbesondere supergut tut. Dass alle jetzt mal wissen, das sind jetzt erst mal die 11 plus 4,5. Der Rest soll halt irgendwie gucken, ob er noch einen Platz findet auf dem ganz ordentlichen trainingsgelände. Aber es ist kein überraschender Pick logischerweise. Aber das muss so sein und es gibt auch gar keinen anderen.
Eine kurze Frage noch, also eigentlich eine große Frage, aber kommt denn dann jetzt Chelsea so langsam in die Spur oder ist Cole Palmer der Einäugige unter den Schlechtziehenden?
Ne, ne, ne. Also es ist schon so, dass Chelsea einen Stil spielt, der hat Probleme, der hat aber auch Vorteile. Sie sind wahrscheinlich im Moment, wenn wir mal so quer überlegen, ja, mit vollem eventuell, ne, aber sind das unterhaltsamste Team der Liga. Das liegt schon auch an Palmer, aber selbst auch in Spielen, in denen er jetzt nicht unbedingt so funktioniert hat wie gegen Bournemouth zum Beispiel. Da gibt es dann andere. Niklas Jackson ist super drauf. Er wird sowas wie die neue Chelsea Nr. 9 Madoecki ist nicht mehr ganz so heiß, wie es mal zwischenzeitlich schon war. Ist aber spielt gut. Enzo Fernández spielt gerade gut. caicedo, weil das System Marescas besser zu ihm passt, sieht sehr gut aus. Kukureya spielt super, ist wahrscheinlich einer der Top 5 Linksverteidiger im Moment weltweit, was ja ein großes Problem war immer mit dem. Chelsea sieht im Moment gut aus, wohlgemerkt sportlich gut aus. Das heißt auf Maresca, glaube ich, das hat immer noch Potenzial, dass es ihm die Ohren fliegt. Aber im Moment, Fernandes, das sieht soweit so gut aus.
Sehr gut. Dann haben wir doch auch noch Chelsea ein bisschen zumindest kurz abgefrühstückt. Dann gehen wir in die Serie A zu Mario. Und da wollen wir über Como sprechen, Mario.
Ja, genau. Ich habe mit Patrick Kotrone rausgepickt, dem Kapitän und Stürmer des Aufsteigers, die jetzt zwei Siege in Folge feiern durften. Die ersten sozusagen seit Rückkehr oder so wie das Konstrukt Como jetzt daherkommt. Vielleicht kann man sogar sagen, die ersten Vereinssiege überhaupt in der obersten Spielklasse Italiens. Einmal nach dem Rückstand noch in Bergamo gewonnen. Da fand ich schon ihn, auch wenn er da noch nicht getroffen hatte, bemerkenswert. Der bringt halt eine Menge Erfahrung mit. Der hat ja auch bei Milan gelernt, ist aber trotzdem auch erst immer noch 6 und 20, ja genau, obwohl er dann zwei paar Jährchen jetzt in der Serie B gespielt hat. Und jetzt am Wochenende mit einem Doppelpack, dann zum 3-2 gegen Hellers. Und ja, ich habe den Namen auch gewählt, um einmal zu sagen, dass Mark Oliver Kempf neben Alberto Morino verteidigt und dann vorschiebt auf Sergio Roberto. Also der Kader ist wild. Und hätte Rafa Varane jetzt nicht seine Karriere aufgrund der Knieverletzung beendet, hätten wir vielleicht die Kombination Mark Oliver Kempf neben Rafa Varane in der Innenverteidigung gesehen. Das wäre schon fantastisch. Komo ist bestimmt nicht die Cinderella-Story und da steckt eine Menge Geld dahinter. Aber trotzdem finde ich es sehr interessant, wie Xesh Fabricas das alles unter einen Hut bekommt und sich jetzt auch auf Dank solcher Spieler wie Patrick Kotrone, dass sie in der Serie A angekommen sind. Weil die haben am Anfang direkt mal 0-3 auf den Deckel bekommen gegen Juve. Aber jetzt sind sie, sie kommen langsam. Und Kotrone kann es auf jeden Fall noch.
Und kurz noch, weil du das angedeutet hast zu den Hintergründen von Komo. Die Brüder Michael Bambang Hartono und Robert Budi Hartono, die laut Forbes ein Frematvermögen von 45 Milliarden Dollar haben. Ja, ich habe alles davon abgelesen, nichts davon wusste ich. Die haben eben Komo sich gekauft und stecken da jetzt richtig Geld rein. Und so konnte man sich wahrscheinlich unter anderem Yannick Engelhardt leisten fürs Mittelfeld von Photonautis Love.
Absolut.
Das ist wirklich der most unlikely. Beziehungsweise eigentlich sieht dieser Kader, wenn man sich das anguckt, von der Zusammenstellung der Spieler her. Also Peppe Rehner hinten drin zum Beispiel noch, dann eben Marc-Oliver Kempf hast du ja schon angesprochen, Yannick Engelhardt und so weiter und so fort. Sieht eigentlich so aus, wie wenn man ein Fußballmanagerspiel spielt.
Ja, daran muss ich auch schon denken.
Sehr schön. Aber es ist doch schön, dass da Patrick Kotrone, der ja auch der Kapitän ist, glaube ich, zumindest in manchen Spielen war es jetzt. Wenn der da überzeugt, ist das ja gut. Und ich bin mir sicher, über Komo werden wir noch stolpern in dieser saison. Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Dann wollen wir noch in die La Liga gucken. Wen hast du uns mitgebracht, Nies?
Ich nenne mal einen Spieler, der im Sommer sowohl die Europameisterschaft als auch die goldmedaille gewonnen hat. Also der so ein bisschen untergeht, wenn es darum geht. Spanien ist neue Talente mit La Minja Mal. Da geht es um Alex Baena. Der ist mir als Madridista durch einen Vorfall mit Fede Valverde, jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz so sympathisch, aber er hat schon eine starke Rückrunde gespielt.
Also was heißt Vorfall? Musst du kurz erklären?
Ah, okay. Ich glaube, das hatten wir auch als Thema. Da hatte Fede Valverde in der letzten Rückrunde um eine mögliche Fehlgeburt gefürchtet.
Ach Gott, das war das. Ja, ja, okay. Jetzt habe ich es wieder.
Okay, das war egal. Aber Baena hat eine starke Rückrunde gespielt, war dann auch mit Villarreal in der Rückrundetabelle auf Platz drei oder vier und jetzt auch in dieser saison sorgen sie bisher für Furore. Baena war letztes Jahr schon der beste Vorlagengeber in der Liga, ist jetzt auch schon mit fünf Assists top dabei. Also nur Vinicius hat einen, noch mehr, hat auch jetzt am Wochenende zuletzt zweimal getroffen. Also Alex Baena ist da richtig stark drauf und macht sogar ein bisschen, ich meine Villarreal hat den Pichichi der Herzen von der letzten saison verloren, Sirlo, das ist so Atletico, aber irgendwie treffen sie weiter auch dank einer Mania aus der Paddels und so weiter. Aber Alex Baena ist da einfach mal auf jeden Fall zu nennen und zu würdigen, wie gesagt, allein weil da vielleicht schon, wenn es darum geht, spanische Talente, denen nicht gleich immer als erstes auffällt. Und bin ich gespannt, wann da irgendwie das erste Angebot aus England kommt. Also hoffen wir mal nicht, dass hier die Chelsea offiziell zuhören, aber ich glaube Una Emery hat ja schon mal mit ihm gearbeitet, war da schon mal dran, von dem her ist Alex Baena da. Ein spannender Name, den man einfach mal so als ganz guten MVP würdigen kann.
Da sind die armen Bayern-Fans, die diese Folge hören, sie haben es sich leist. Erst wurde die ganze Zeit auf Serge Nabry eingetroschen und jetzt auch noch der Champions League-Gruppenspielschreck genannt, nämlich Una Emery. Letzte Gruppenspielphase, Niederlage vor sieben Jahren für Bayern, trainer des Gegners damals, Una Emery. Aber gut, soll dem Besten passiert sein. Ich bin ja jetzt auch darüber hinweggegangen, dass Atletico und Real ja auch beide ihre Spiele verloren haben. Ich dachte eigentlich, dass Alexi das als Geschichte des Jahres mitbringt, den Sieg von Lille, aber offenbar…
Bleib bescheiden, wir haben noch mehr vor.
Wir haben noch mehr vor. Ja, unter anderem ja, dass wir über deinen Ansatz Hero sprechen wollen. Wen hast du uns denn da mitgebracht, Alexi?
Stadt Breis ist Tabellen-Zweiter. Aber nicht in der Liga, sondern in der Champions League.
In der Champions League, ja.
Hero? Weiß ich gar nicht mehr. Da muss ich mich dran erinnern.
Wir wollen jetzt über Straßburg sprechen, an der Stelle.
Ah, den trainer von Straßburg, ja. Genau, ein völlig Unbekannter, Liam Roseniore, ein Engländer, der zwei Jahre bei Halftime City gearbeitet hat. Und das Merkwürdige ist, bei Straßburg, dass er die Mannschaft übernahm ein paar Tage vor dem saisonauftritt, sodass er die saisonvorbereitung gar nicht mitgemacht hat. Er kam von heute auf morgen, weil es mit Patrick Vieira nicht mehr geklappt hat. Patrick Vieira war ein Riesenspieler, aber kein guter trainer. Bei Liam Rosenjohr ist es wohl das Gegenteil. Er hatte eine bescheidene Karriere bei Brighton unter anderem. Jetzt macht er sich als trainer sehr, sehr gut. Ich sage das, weil Straßburg zwar nur auf der Welt im Platz 8 steht, aber nach sechs Spieltagen ist Straßburg die Mannschaft mit dem attraktivsten Fußball. Es wird wirklich heiß her und sie ist die jüngste Mannschaft mit Abstand, der Liga 1. Das ist ein bisschen das Modell wie Red Bull Salzburg, nur Salzburg vor fünf, sechs Jahren nicht das heutige Auslaufmodell. Aber bei Straßburg läuft es richtig gut, auch dieses Zusammenspiel. Das Triple Pass-Spiel zwischen Straßburg und Chelsea. Man hat ja selbst Eigentümer und Chelsea schickt gerne Spieler rüber ins Elters. Es wurde sehr kritisch beäugt, aber wie Straßburg gerade auftrumpft mit diesem Rosenjohr als trainer, das ist wirklich sehr begeisternd. Nur diese Mannschaft, wie schon erwähnt, sehr jung, also muss noch reifen, vor allem im Defensivbereich bei Ballverlust. Aber Rosenjohr korrigiert mit dem Spiel, wenn es schief läuft. Taktisch, personell, und es läuft. Und es ist auch erfolgreich, was er macht. Wie zum Beispiel in Lille, man lag 1-3 zurück, und es stand am Ende 3-3. Oder auch zuletzt im Olympique Marseille, die erste Niederlage zugefügt, 1-0 zu Hause. Da herrscht eine gewisse, leichte, aber interessante Euphorie im Elsass. Man weiß, dass Straßburg vielleicht einer der besten Fanszene hat in Frankreich. Und man wäre nicht verwundert, wenn am Ende der saison Straßburg sich für einen Europapokal qualifiziert. Also nicht Champions League, aber Europa League oder Confirmations League ist auf jeden Fall drin.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, Uli, wie du in der Championship drin warst, aber hast du das kommen sehen, dass Rosignol so…
Ja, war, glaube ich, nach den ersten zwei, drei Spielen schon klar. Der ist ja damals eingesprungen als, glaube ich, noch spielertrainer seiner Zeit schon. Und da war schon sehr, sehr schnell klar, der Typ hat's. Also es war in England schon einer, der ist ein bisschen kleiner. Das hat man in England nicht so gern bei Bosses. Das hat man immer gesagt, dass der eventuell nicht ganz so die Autorität sein könnte.
Von der Körpergröße her jetzt kleiner. Ja.
Das war ein großes Thema bei ihm.
Das Jan Sommer-Thema quasi. Jetzt auch bei trainern.
Genau. Genau. Jetzt Sommer.
Was ist los mit dem Fußball?
Das war immer ein großes Thema bei Rosinia. Aber dass der Typ einfach ein unfassbares fußball-brain hat, das war sehr, sehr, sehr schnell klar, dass der einer sein würde. Der war auch schon innerhalb des ersten halben Jahres bei irgendeinem Premier-League-Team in der Theorie zumindest genannt worden. War, glaube ich, sogar so etwas wie Brighton, also irgendein sehr datenorientierter Ansatz. Aber das macht man ja in der Premier League nicht so gerne, jemanden aus der zweiten Liga zu holen. Das passiert ja so gut wie nie. Da ist ja fast gar keine Durchlässigkeit diesbezüglich. Und dann ist der Name wieder etwas verschwunden. Mich hat es dann ein wenig gewundert, als ich das gelesen hatte, dass er zu Straßburg geht. Aber so wie Alexi das jetzt erklärt hat, mit dem Konstrukt dahinter, ist es dann wieder einigermaßen sinnvoll. Aber er ist ein trainer, den ich auf dem Schirm hatte.
Ja, faszinierend. Okay, aber es baut uns gleich die Brücke zu deinem Ansang, Hero. Denn wir bleiben im Bereich der trainer.
Ja, das ist wieder der Mokler, den ich hier einmal drin habe vor Ligatour. So kann ich dir schön Fulham unterjubeln. Naja, aber im Ernst ist wirklich, glaube ich, auch wieder die Definition eines Ansangheroes, Marco Silva, trainer von Fulham, weil sie sehr gut gestartet sind mit einem Programm, zugegebenermaßen, das machbar ist für Fulham. So hätten sie es auch ungefähr machen müssen, um potenziell die Möglichkeit, sich zu erhalten, einstellig zu werden, aber warum nenne ich Silva? Weil in dem Verein stimmt nicht immer alles. Man ist nicht so ganz glücklich mit, wie die Fans behandelt werden. Es wird immer teurer. Man ist nicht so ganz glücklich mit teilweise späten Transferentscheidungen. Einerseits Abgänge von Top-Top-Spielern. Diesmal ist João Paulinho zwar relativ früh gegangen, aber im Jahr davor spät. Der Director der Fußball kümmert sich ganz viel um Wrestling und nicht so viel um Fußball, wie er sollte und so weiter und so weiter. Und Markus Silva ist aber derjenige, der es immer wieder hinbringt, eine neue Mannschaft zu formen. Er hat ganz klammheimlich wahrscheinlich das physischste Team der Liga aufgebaut. Es ist erstaunlich, wie viel Athletik, wie viel Wucht, wie viel einfach grundsätzlich Präsenz, aber auch Schnelligkeit, Dynamik in dem Kader ist. Und ist jemand, den, glaube ich, den verehren sie inzwischen im Graven Cottage, weil er eben ein Team geschaffen hat, das nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun haben wird. Niemals. Im Gegenteil, vielleicht sogar, wenn sie Glück haben, irgendwann mal zu den– das sind ja eigentlich keine Big Six mehr, wir sind ja eher schon jetzt Top 8 oder so, wenn man Newcastle und Villa noch mit reinzählen will. Und ich glaube, Essenwehr muss man inzwischen da jetzt mit reinnehmen. Und vielleicht kann Fulham sogar zumindest einmal aufschließen dazu. Auch im Cup zuletzt einen ordentlichen Run gehabt, nah dran gewesen, mal im Halbfinale zumindest gestanden. Ein sehr Storatyp. Er wurde ja mal aus Miniu Mourinho gelabelt. Er hat mal einen Job in Portugal verloren, weil er sich geweigert hat, zum Bankett einen Anzug anzuziehen. Sondern wollte im trainingsanzug kommen. Also da wird irgendwas anderes gewesen sein. Aber so ist die offizielle Verlautbarung gewesen, dass er sich nicht an den Kontakt gehalten hat. Und jetzt ist er beim 4. Premier League Club. Und bei dem scheint es jetzt wirklich hundertprozentig hinzuhauen.
Stark. Und ich sehe schon die Anzang Hero Kategorie. Die ist offenbar prädestiniert für trainer, weil die nicht so oft besungen werden. Denn auch Mario hat uns einen trainer mitgebracht. Wer ist es geworden?
Ja, genau. Ich habe gedacht, ich schließe mich da direkt an. Es ist Marco Baroni. Letzte saison hat er das fast Unmögliche möglich gemacht und Hellas in der Serie A gehalten. Auch deswegen ist er auf den Radar von größeren Clubs gekommen. Er hat bei Lazio übernommen. Da war ich super skeptisch. Man muss sagen, bei Lazio ist ein Riesenumbruch. Sergej Mlinković-Savić ist dem Ruf des Gelbes gefolgt. In die Emirate, Ciro Immobile ist nach Zubeşiktaş gegangen. Auch ein Zocker wie Luis Alberto hat nicht mehr da, die immer super wichtig waren. Also alles neu. Marco Boroni hat jetzt vier seiner ersten sieben Spiele gewonnen. Auch einer in der Europa League war dabei, ein ziemlich überzeugender. Wie er das geschafft hat und wie er es dann geschafft hat, in dem Zuge auch noch so Spieler wie Gwendou Zid zum absoluten Leistungsträger zu etablieren, hat mich schon auf jeden Fall beeindruckt, weil der auch immer einer war, der auf dem schmalen Grad zwischen– also Genie würde ich es dann noch nicht in den Mund nehmen wollen, aber auch einer, der schon zeigt, dass er Fußball spielen kann, aber auch immer wieder Spiele und Aussetzer hatte, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das reicht eigentlich nicht für weiter oben. Und jetzt hält er da im Mittelfeld das Ding beisammen. Ein Zarcani hat die Kapitänsbinde übernommen, den man auch aus der italienischen Nationalmannschaft kennt. Also da ist nicht alles nur irgendwie B-Ware, was rumläuft an Spielern, aber das ist trotzdem angesichts der Fluktuation auch auf vor allem wichtigen Positionen, was Mannschafts-Chirurgie angeht, bemerkenswert, wie Baroni so zumindest jetzt den saisonstart für Lazio gestaltet hat. Das hätte ich ihnen auf jeden Fall nicht zugetraut, sondern ich glaube, ich habe sie bei uns in der saisonvorschau sogar auf einen fast zweistelligen Tabellenrang getippt. Deswegen nutze ich die Kategorie auch hier, sozusagen, um schon mal ein bisschen Abhitte zu leisten bei Lazio und Marco Baroni.
Das wird das neue Ding, der Ablasshandel des Rasenfunks. Hier könnt ihr euch freisprechen von euren rhetorischen Sünden der Vergangenheit. Da bin ich dann zuerst mein eigener Kunde, ehrlicherweise muss man dazu sagen. Und wir bleiben bei den Tränen, denn auch du, Nils, möchtest uns über jemanden was erzählen, der es auch geschafft hat, mit seinem Team tatsächlich aktuell in den Top 6 zu stehen.
Genau. Ich mache das trainer-quintet komplett. Und da geht es um einen trainer, der wird bei seinem neuen Verein bestimmt schon ein bisschen besungen, aber noch nicht unbedingt in der Öffentlichkeit. Wenn man sich die La-Liga-Tabelle anschaut, fällt als erstes bestimmt auch der Tabell in Sechste auf. Das ist der Real Club Deportivo Mallorca. Und dort ist Jacubo Arasate. Der war die letzten sechs Jahre durchaus sehr erfolgreich bei Ossasuna, hat da ganz gut mit Nachwuchs gearbeitet, kam ins Pokalfinale und so weiter. Ist dann aber freiwillig gegangen, wollte nicht mehr verlängern. Um sich jetzt einer gefühlt noch größeren Herausforderung Mallorca, wo du vielleicht auch ein bisschen überschaubares Spielmaterial hast, die ich ganz so viel Nachwuchs hast, da hat er sich angeschlossen dem Club. Und aktuell gab es, glaube ich, zuletzt drei Siege in Folge. Haben auch zuvor schon gegen Real Madrid ein 1 zu 1 zu Hause geholt, wie schon oft ein Kader, der gar nicht so stark verändert wurde. Also er hat jetzt keinen von Ossasuna mitgenommen. Von VfL Bochum kam natürlich Arzano, aber auch der ist mehr so Ergänzungsspieler. Und Mallorca hat an sich begrenzte, überschaubare spielerische Mittel. Da ist auch natürlich viel defensive Disziplin, viele lange Bälle. Murici vorne ist ein absoluter Knipser. Und trotzdem holen sie irgendwie aus gefühlt wenig sehr viel raus, sind schwer zu bespielen, sehr diszipliniert. Dani Rodriguez spielt eine gute saison natürlich. Und da führt Arasate die Arbeit von seinem Vorgänger Javi Aguirre. Der hatte Mallorca jetzt auch ins Pokalfinale geführt. Führt er ganz gut fort. Und ja, irgendwie sind sie da selbst in gewissen Statistiken auch so im Mittelfeld hinsichtlich. Abschlüsse, sogar ein bisschen Ballbesitzer. Es ist jetzt nicht nur mauern und eklig sein, aber das können sie schon auch. Und wie gesagt, durchaus effizient und holen da raus, was geht. Und deswegen ist Platz 6 aktuell gar nicht mal unverdient.
Durchaus effizient bei acht geschossenen Toren und sechs kassierten Toren sind 14 Punkte. Da hat man die richtige Verteilung der Tore und Gegentore auf jeden Fall gewählt. Sehr schön haben wir Mallorca auch mal wieder hier untergebracht in der Ligatur. Dann haben wir noch unsere Geschichte der Woche. Wir beginnen wieder in der Ligue 1. Alexi, was hast du uns mitgebracht?
Ja, der tiefe Abstieg oder Fall von Gérard-Andre Bordeaux war der traditionsreichste Verein der Frankreichs in der Geschichte. Jetzt steht man in der fünften Liga, vergleichbar mit der Asien-Club Straßburg vor knapp zehn Jahren. Nur Straßburg ist hier letztes Jahr aufgestiegen. Es steht jetzt solid in der ersten Liga. Ob es Gérard-Andre schafft, wage ich zu bezweifeln, weil da viel zu viel Unruhe herrscht. Vor allem das größte Gift dieses Abstiegs heißt Gérard Lopez, ein luxemburgischer Unternehmer, der schon in den OSC Lille vor fünf, sechs Jahren in die Ruine geführt hat. Und jetzt macht er das Gleiche mit Gérard-Bordeaux. Natürlich traurig, weil solche Namen brauchst du in der Ligue 1. Man war schon im Omburgal-Finale, früher hatte man herausragende Spieler wie Sarazou, Degary, aber vor allem sind sie dann. Und jetzt spielt man vor 200 Zuschauern im Durchschnitt. Man hat World Cup-Grode von Amir.
Ist da alle Fans weggebrochen? Können die nicht mehr in ihrem Stadion spielen? Oder 200 Zuschauer?
Die dürfen momentan nicht in ihrem Stadion spielen, weil ein Verein, der in der fünften Liga spielt, darf nicht in seinem Stadion spielen. In Frankreich sind fast keine Tribüne da sogar. Und auch 200 natürlich auswärts, darunter 150 aus Bordeaux. Also wie gesagt, sehr, sehr traurig. Ich weiß nicht, wie es da weitergeht. Aber die haben auch die Liga gestartet mit zwei Spieltagen später, sodass die die ersten beiden Spiele auf dem grünen Teppich verloren haben und bisher noch keinen einzigen Sieg auf dem Konto haben. Und so wird es auch schwer, sofort aufzusteigen am Ende der saison. Auch wenn sich da ehemalige Spieler angemeldet haben und der Kader mehr als 30 Spieler momentan zusammenfasst.
Kannst du das nochmal kurz erklären, warum Teams nicht in ihrem eigenen Stadion spielen, in der fünften Liga?
Das ist, weil die Liga nicht mehr Profi ist. Also du hast einen Amateur-Status. Und wenn es so ist, darfst du nicht in einer so modernen Arena spielen, wie Bordeaux der Nord-Atlantik. Das ist halt eine komische Regel, aber das steht in den Status des fantastischen Liga-Verbandes.
Der französische Fußballer, er schafft es immer wieder, mich aufs Neue zu faszinieren. Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Ich meine, also eigentlich müsste man da zu einem Tribüngespräch machen, zu diesem Downfall, und eigentlich müsste man zu der Person Gerard Lopez ein Tribüngespräch machen. Das ist ja Wahnsinn, wie man als Totengräber gleich mehrere Vereine von einem zum nächsten ziehen kann und einfach nur, weil man viel Geld mitbringt, kommt aus dem Private-Equity-Bereich, werden da ihm die Tore aufgemacht, aber Wahnsinn. Okay. Es ist wirklich heftig. Und ich meine, wenn wir dann noch TV-Vertrag, 2. Liga zum Beispiel noch mit angucken, da könnte man noch drüber sprechen, Montagsspiele und so weiter und so fort. Also die Liga, bzw. dieses Gesamtkonstrukt bewirbt sich schon sehr, sehr lange dafür, dass ich da irgendwann mal mit mehr Zeit draufschaue. Aber schön, dass Bordeaux wenigstens hier noch kurz stattgefunden hat. Dieser Downfall ist wirklich schlimm. Ja, jetzt weiß ich auch nicht, wie die Überleitung sein kann. Jetzt zur nächsten Geschichte der Preparate League. Vor allem, weil ich nicht weiß, welche Geschichte es ist.
Ich weiß es bis jetzt auch noch nicht ganz genau, welche ich nehme. Ich habe erst überlegt, es wird schon ein bisschen rauer zwischen Arsenal und City, aber es ist alles langweilig. Es ist so viel Day-to-Day, dass ich mir gedacht habe, ich nehme mal was anderes, weil es mich total verwundert hat und weil ich es aber überragend finde. Ich mache mal ein kurzes Schlenker zum US-Präsidentschaftswahlkampf im November. Klar. Ja, logisch.
Fußball ist unpolitisch, Uli. Ich möchte es dir nur noch mal sagen.
Ja, genau. Das ist auch Most Random, einer der komischsten Crossovers, die ich je gesehen habe. Ich weiß auch gar nicht genau, wie Sie darauf gekommen sind. Auf der einen Seite ist es so genial. Es gibt ein TikTok-Video von Kamala Harris. Hast du es schon gesehen? Ich fand das überragend. Es gibt einen Kommentar von Alan Schirra live für die BBC während des F-Media-Schießens Englands gegen die Schweiz bei der Europameisterschaft. Da wird er nach Druck gefragt. Er sagt, was für Druck, Druck ist was für Reifen. Genau diese Phrase haben sie eingebaut, über ein paar Bilder gelegt von Trump und seinem designierten Vize. Das ist einfach nur eine Geschichte, die bringt jetzt keinen weiter. Aber ich finde das weltklasse. Das ist so ein Schirr-Thing, der als Experte einfach, ehrlich, niemanden weiterbringt. Das war das Beste, was er je gesagt hat. Das fand ich auch wirklich irgendwie witzig, wie er es so rübergebracht hat in seiner Art und Weise. Und dass das jetzt US-Präsidentschaftswahlkampf landet, finde ich irgendwie stark. Deswegen war ich sonst nirgends wohin verwenden kann.
Das war super.
Sehr, sehr gut. Sie hätte es nur toppen können, wenn sie da Oli Kahn drüber gelegt hätte. Vielleicht hat er auch noch was zu Druck gesagt. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Nee, glaube ich nicht. Kann ich mir schwer vorstellen. Ja, das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass wir...
Ich? Wo war ich unsicher?
Okay, sehr schön. Kamala Harris. Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass wir die hier auch noch unterbringen. Mario, wen hast du dabei?
Ich habe im weitesten Sinne Claudio, genannt, Boccia, Gallimberti dabei. Und da tauchen wir sozusagen jetzt ab in einen Filmtipp. Wir hatten vorhin ja schon einmal die Ultras angesprochen. Es kommt jetzt demnächst, am 10.10. ist Deutschland-Premiere in Frankfurt, eine Dokumentation über einen in Italien sehr bekannten Atalanta-Ultra in die Kinos. Aguabia di Una Fede, kann man übersetzen so ein bisschen mit Wächter eines Glaubens. Eine sehr streitbare Person auf jeden Fall. Der hat auch nicht alles richtig gemacht in seinem Leben. Aber auch sehr viel Gutes bewirkt. Wir können uns vielleicht auch zurückerinnern an die Covid-Zeit in Bergamo. Die Ultras haben die Stadt am Leben gehalten. Der hat viel gemacht. Gegen den sind viele Prozesse geführt worden, auch in Italien. Inzwischen ist er ein Steuermann auf einem Fischerboot. Ich habe Teile davon schon gesehen, noch nicht alles. Deswegen ist es natürlich auch ein Filmtipp, den ich nicht komplett belegen kann. Aber ich glaube, es ist auf jeden Fall interessant, sich das anzugucken. Der kommt dann auch nach München. Sogar mal mit Produzent und Regisseur sind auch da. Danach kommt er auch einfach so in die Kinos. Wahrscheinlich ist nicht immer in einem Cinemax, Mathezer etc., aber man wird es bestimmt in Programmkinos finden. Eine Sache in der Filmankündigung, die ich irgendwie ganz passend fand, der Regisseur Zambelli beschreibt auch den Prozess, durch den der Fußball von einem Sport für alle zum globalen Geschäft wurde, bis die Tribünen durch die Covid-Pandemie schließlich leer blieben. Und alles halt aufgehängt an Claudio Boccia Gallimberti aus Bergamo, der da lange Zeit der Anführer der Curva Nord war, bis er dann auch lange Jahre nicht im Stadion sein durfte und ins Exil gegangen ist. Ich glaube, alle, die sich ein bisschen für ihre Fankultur und italienische Fankultur interessieren, ist das auf jeden Fall eine Pflichtveranstaltung.
Aber wirklich, wird unter anderem gezeigt in Frankfurt, in München, in Düsseldorf, in Gelsenkirchen, Leipzig, Hamburg, Magdeburg und Berlin. Ich werde einen Link in die Show notes packen und wir gucken mal, ob wir vielleicht so einen Ligatour mitwirkenden Treffen da rund um die Münchentermine hinbekommen. Da es Männer-Länderspiel kommen, können wir darauf verzichten auf die Premiere von Jannis Plasvik im Tor von Deutschland. Und den Dreierpack von Tim Kleindienst, den sehen wir ja dann in den Highlights. Was sehen wir, wenn wir nach La Liga noch ein letztes Mal blicken, Nies?
Das ist jetzt keine große, witzige Geschichte. Es ist eher eine Sache, was beim FC Barcelona jetzt passiert ist, wo jemand aus dem Ruhestand geholt wurde. Das, was man sich bei Ray Madrid vielleicht auch wünschen würde, so, hey Toni, hast du an den Wochenenden wirklich so viel zu tun? Magst du dich nochmal die Schuhe schüren? Nein, bei Barca, Testegen habt ihr natürlich alle mitbekommen. Paar Teller sehen Riss quasi saison aus. Und Iñaki Peña, Ersatz Torwart, hat man nicht zugetraut, dass er jetzt über die saison hinweg da die Nummer eins ist. Deswegen hat man geschaut, so, wen man holen kann. Es gibt ja dann die Regel, vertragslose oder freie Torhüter darf man dann noch verpflichten. Da gab es ein paar Kandidaten, Loris Karius hat es nicht geschafft. Aber es ist die Wahl gefallen, jetzt auch offiziell auf Wojciech Czesny. Dessen Vertrag bei Juve war ausgelaufen und dann hat er sich hier und da noch so ein bisschen fit gehalten und gehofft, vielleicht kriegt er noch was. Aber eigentlich hat er dann auch schon gesagt, dass er dann eigentlich schon wieder abgeschlossen hatte, dann sein Karriereende bekannt gegeben hat. Und ja, aber dann irgendwie kam die Verletzung. Lewandowski hat dann schnell das Handy gezückt und seinen Ex-Kollegen von der Nationalmannschaft angerufen. Und ja, jetzt ist er auf einmal da. Bin gespannt, wie fit er ist, weil er ist ja auch bekannt so ein bisschen als Lebe-Mann, der auch gerne mal das Leben genießt, wie er da jetzt von der Fitness da ist. Aber es gab natürlich Medizin-Check und alles. Also, Czesny ist zurück, das ist so die Geschichte, dass er da jetzt der Testigen-Ersatz ist. Man weiß natürlich noch nicht, wie fit er ist. Und ich glaube, letztes Jahr bei Juve war er ja noch voll gesetzt, kam auf über 30 Spiele. Da kann vielleicht auch Mario noch was sagen, ob er da auf jeden Fall noch ein guter ist, wovon ich mal ausgehe. Er ist ja jetzt noch keine 40 oder so, 35, glaube ich, 34, ja.
Ja, also mich hat voll gefreut, dass ich das gelesen habe, weil ich finde, dass es eigentlich irgendwie ein, zwei Jahre zu früh war noch, dass er die Fußballschuhe an den Nagel gehängt hat. Aber bei Juve hat man sich halt entschlossen, irgendwie da den nächsten Schritt zu gehen und die Gregorio zu holen. jaisnijsa, habe ich das mitbekommen, glaube ich, er so Saudi- oder so League Cater machen können, aber das wollte er halt auch nicht, auch wegen Familie und so. Das ist auch schon wieder was allein dafür. Ich glaube, charakterlich ist er ein guter, der bei Barca ins Team kommt. Und der war schon viele Jahre und da nehme ich mich selber auch nicht mit aus, so ein bisschen unterm Radar, ein bisschen underrated. Aber was der für eine, also man hat ihn vielleicht dann noch mit seinen Anfangszeiten auch mal bei Arsenal, da hat er schon immer Spiele drin gehabt. Aber wie er sich dann weiterentwickelt hat, zu einer echt festen Torwartgröße, der hinten raus auch noch das Spiel mit dem Ball am Fuß gelernt hat. Also von daher glaube ich passt er dann auch als Ersatz für Ter Stegen ganz gut.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir so eben die Verletzung von Ter Stegen, die jetzt schon eine ganze Weile ja zurückliegt und die jeder mitbekommen hat. Aber finde ich schön, dass wir die auch noch erwähnt haben. Ich meine, das ist ja auch nochmal eine ganz eigene Geschichte mit verschiedensten Dimensionen. Dass es jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt dann eine so schwere Verletzung sein muss. Aber so ist es eben. Ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Es hat großen Spaß wieder gemacht, zu euren Ligen zu sprechen. Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich mache das jetzt wieder kollektiv. Ziehen wir das nicht unnötig in die Länge. Danke, dass ihr die Zeit hattet für den Rasenfunk. Wie immer eine große Freude und ich freue mich, wenn wir dann alle zusammen ins Kino gehen. Das ist doch jetzt hiermit beschlossen, oder? Also danke euch.
Klassenfahrt, juhu.
Sehr gut.
Danke für die Einladung.
Ich danke euch für die, wie immer, sehr gute Vorbereitung und ich danke auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern da draußen, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Dafür, dass ihr diese Folge weiterempfehlt, bewertet, dem Rasenfunk gewogen bleibt und dass ihr den Rasenfunk ermöglicht. Denn ihr wisst ja, alles, was wir hier machen, ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wie funktioniert das, fragt ihr. Das funktioniert nur über euch und über Menschen wie Marie65P, 93, ThomasMD, Yannick, Klaus-Dieter, PdeWollitz, nicht der echte, vermutlich, und Taktikteufel. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de slash-supportersclub gegangen, denn da erfährt man, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Geht via Paypal, Kreditkarte, Banküberweisung, kleine Beträge, große Beträge, alles ist willkommen und fließt eben in die Gäste, ins Programm der Rasenfunk. Er wird sich weiterentwickeln. Dank euch. Herzlichen Dank dafür, rasenfunk.de slash-supportersclub. Bleibt gesund, bis bald, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.